la France a rapatrié aujourd'hui 15
femmes et 32 enfants qui étaient détenus
dans les camps de prisonniers
djihadistes en Syrie a annoncé le
ministère des Affaires étrangères
l'avion s'est posé ce matin sur le
tarmac de l'aéroport de Villacoublay et
les 32 enfants ont été remis au service
chargé de l'aide à l'enfant et ils
feront l'objet d'un suivi médico-social
les adultes ont-elles été remise aux
autorités judiciaires compétentes c'est
la troisième opération de rapatriement
de grande ampleur elle est intervenue
après la condamnation de la France par
le Comité contre la torture des Nations
Unies qui avait adopté le 16 janvier un
texte dénonçant la politique française
de rapatriement au compte-goutte ce
Comité considère que la tiédeur des
autorités françaises a rapatriés ces
ressortissants constituent une violation
des articles 2 et 16 de la Convention
contre la torture et les traitements
inhumains ou dégradants l'État demeure
toujours dans l'obligation de les
protéger contre des violations graves
des droits de l'homme en prenant toutes
les mesures nécessaires et possibles ces
Français s'étaient rendus volontairement
dans les territoires contrôlés par les
groupes djihadistes en zone Irako
syrienne elles avaient été capturées au
moment de la chute de l'organisation de
l'État islamique en 2019 leurs enfants
sont pour nombre d'entre eux nés dans
les camps comme pour les femmes
rapatriées en octobre dernier c'est
françaises devraient être rapidement mis
en examen et placé en détention
provisoire pour association de
malfaiteurs terroristes et criminels
elle risque la prison à perpétuité les
enfants sont eux pris en charge par
l'aide sociale à l'enfance dès leur
arrivée sur le sol français et de
nombreux spécialistes sont mobilisés
pour les encadrer Nour éducatrice
spécialisée s'est confié au magazine
Marianne en octobre dernier sur ce
qu'elle avait pu entendre de la part de
ses enfants ma maman m'a dit que je
n'avais pas le droit d'écouter de la
musique mon papa me dit qu'on n'est pas
comme vous vous êtes des mécréants mon
papa m'a dit qu'en France on ne peut pas
être musulman les Français ne respectent
pas notre religion ma maman m'a dit que
je ne devais pas parler avec les garçons
environ 300 mineurs français ayant
séjourné dans des zones d'opérations de
groupe terroristes sont déjà rentrés en
France dont 77 par un patrimo il
décembre un collectif de famille de
ressortissantes françaises détenus
avaient indiqué que 150 enfants
restaient encore parqués dans les camps
de prisonniers syriens
[Musique]